foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook without sense after
two years of covid misery Britain faces
a new plague of festive strikes I'll
take on one of the union leaders hell
bent on wrecking on Christmas
Donald Trump's family business is
convicted for the tax fraud and another
of his
pick goes down in flames in the senate
race is it time up for Trump well his
former Chief White House a Killian
Conway joins me to defend him
plus it's been 50 years today since we
last launched a rocket to the moon
carrying a human being why why have we
stopped doing it the Superstar Astro
businesses Neil deGrasse Tyson joins me
live to explain
[Music]
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening Fernando
welcome to Pierce Morgan on since the
last two Christmases were raped by
coronavirus pubs were deserted office
parties canceled many people stayed home
to protect their elderly relatives this
year it's an epidemic of strikes
infecting our holiday spirit and the
super spreader is rmt Union boss Mick
Lynch here's a reminder what he said
just a couple of weeks ago
we have left the Christmas period strike
free deliberately we cannot leave this
action to go cold we've not been on
strike for two months we moved other
dates to facilitate uh important public
and National events
well congratulations on showing up to
work for two entire months mate but your
festive tune has changed three new rail
strikes including one that callously
begins on Christmas Eve will throttle
family plans and Crush business for bars
restaurants and shops truly Mr Lynch is
the Grinch who's trolled Christmas and
here's what he now has to say about
wrecking our holidays
the public will lose the convenience of
having a train service the businesses
around here and all around London and
all over the country will lose money
undoubtedly the only people that won't
lose money are the train operating
companies
more festive snare than festive cheer
but he's right businesses will lose
money millions of people will suffer
what he can't seem to accept is that is
because of him the British people have
been very patient and sympathetic with
Nick Lynch and the Striking unions but
that tide is now turning a new pole by
yougov shows that more than half of the
country now opposes these strikes it's
hard to pose as a worker's hero when a
quarter of all Christmas bookings have
already been canceled over transport
hell and precisely the time businesses
make the money they depend on all year
and I'm afraid the kimono virus as we're
now calling it is highly contagious one
million workers nearly every Trade union
of either confirmed strikes or called
strike ballots is winter Britain could
face strikes every single day until
Christmas it's the Advent calendar from
hell
well postal workers will wreck Christmas
deliveries border staff and baggage
handlers at London airports will Scupper
Christmas getaways nurses and ambulance
workers will strike potentially risking
lies this is flu season and about
potentially covert outbreak and winter
demand hits are bad at NHS I've always
supported workers and many of these
union members do deserve a pay rise
unquestionably these are desperately
tough times to millions of people but
most of these people are showing up for
work so they can pay their rocketing
bills frankly they deserve a proper
Christmas too well joining me now is the
unite National lead officer oneai kasab
well welcome to you thank you very much
why are you wrecking Christmas
we're not wrecking Christmas
we're not wrecking Christmas our members
take action strike action as a last
resort and particularly in the NHS this
is a heartbreaking decision for our
members
our members are taking strike action
because the government is refusing to
negotiate on pay but our members as
nurses paramedics have also asked me to
make very very clear that this is more
than just about pay this is about saving
the NHS there's a crisis in the NHS and
our members are prepared to do something
about it how do you have a crisis in the
NHS when at the very busiest time for
the NHS of all in the run-up to
Christmas you potentially are going to
put people's lives at risk what if
people start dying because ambulances
didn't turn up what if people start
dying because the nursing staff simply
weren't there enough numbers to save
them how are you guys going to live with
yourselves the harsh reality is that
people are dying now and this is coming
from our paramedic man so kill a few
more is that your business absolutely
not absolutely
you're responsible for the ambulance
workers right you personally what
happens if as a result of a strike
action on December 23rd If it goes ahead
people die because of a strike action
how do you live with that morally people
are dying now the question is
if I could just finish how would you
live morally people with that happening
is a direct concept of your Striker
people are dying now as a direct
consequence of the government not taking
action you're playing water boundary no
no no I'm asking you not what's going on
already that is why so your answer is to
have more deaths absolutely just answer
for a second we'll answer this is why
this is why we are sitting down
with the employers with government
making sure that there are emergency
measures in place to make sure that we
do these emergencies even during strike
action look just just let me make this
point I really want you to answer my
question it's a very specific question
yes how would you live with yourself
morally as a union leader if ambulance
workers guide on strike because you
can't do a deal with the government and
because of that strike action
directly because of it people die now
people are dying directly no you keep
saying that I know people are dying I
know the NHS is in trouble you don't
want to let me finish just for a second
no because I want you to answer my
question answering your question first
of all we are negotiating with the
government to make sure there are
emergency measures I did
um
what I wanted to carry on
come on what I wanted to carry on and
say you're smirking at me why I'm asking
you a very soon
consistently refusing to answer no I'm
not refusing answer my question our
strike action will take place over one
day of the year why should people die
that day ambulance workers these are in
the emergency services 364 days of the
year this is the busiest week of the
year for ambulance work to be nothing
look here's the guarantee I will give if
the government says to us tomorrow they
are sitting to they are willing to sit
down and negotiate with us then we will
sit down and negotiate with them that's
the problem will you guarantee me that
nobody will die if the strike goes ahead
as a direct result of a strikeout I can
guarantee you that if there are
emergencies our members will come off
the picket lines to deal with those they
won't strike our members and it's been
done for our members will come off
picket lines to deal with emergence how
fast are they going to come off a picket
line get back in the round but it's
going to save somebody's life and it's
an emergency
I've already said earlier on we will
negotiate measures in place our
membership responding to my direct
questions which are simple questions by
answering something completely different
no no our members will even come off
picket lines if I remember how long
would it take them to get from a picket
line to their ambulance to go and save a
life in an emergency you know you know I
can't answer that in minutes but the
reality no no here's the reality how do
you know they can get there in time
peace
you're asking me a ridiculous you said
they would come off picket lines if
there's an emergency I think it's a
fairly logical question to then say to
you if they come off their picket line
in an emergency how long does it take
for them to get to their ambulance and
get to the emergency and Save Somebody
how about the fact that this is taking
place 300 do you know how long it take
days of the year already yeah I know how
about if you want to talk about timing
if you want to talk about timing how
about this the fact that the majority of
uh targets with regard to uh emergency
call out responses are not met right
isn't that what we should say your
answer is to make things worse
your comfort blanket is to say if
somebody is having an emergency
your members will come off a picket line
but then go and save their lives but I'm
asking you this well hang on I'm asking
hang on I'm asking you the obvious
supplementary question how long would it
take them to come off a picket line and
go and save somebody's life and you know
you don't know no and you know I'm not
going to give you minutes that you don't
know do your friends on the circumstance
you don't know because it depends on the
reality is absolutely in that
circumstances a lot of people might die
but we're not just going to rely on
people coming off the picket lines we
will negotiate measures with the
employers to make sure that there are
emergency measures in place but the
moment you want more than inflation
Rises right we we use we use the RPI
more than inflation 14.2 percent that's
the cost of living right you are 14.2
pay Rises busting inflation yes right
and you think presumably you think all
public sector workers should get the
same we're all striking well for you the
special ones no no no they're all good
the same not the special ones they all
get the same we organize across 41
different sectors we don't think any
worker should be treated better than the
other right so every okay
so everybody should get 14.2 percent
everybody deserves a decent pay increase
I don't mean to be mean or rude but you
never actually answer my question you
just smirk or laugh which I find really
bizarre giving you represent ambulance
workers in a potential emergency so let
me just try again do you believe then if
everyone should be treated the same that
everyone should get a 14.2 pay rise we
believe every worker should be entitled
the same so cost of living increase so
14.2 look but hold on don't say look and
ask something else no no I want to
clarify one hang on I asked the
questions yes 14.2 for every public
sector worker that's yeah that's what
you think we believe every public
Madness if you could just let me finish
for one why your plan is to bankrupt the
country we're already on the verge of it
thanks to the incompetent government
14.2 everybody gets 14 by two percent
you bankrupt Britain no no we don't yes
you do no we don't 14.2 is the RPI
measure of inflation the cost of living
increase however here's the reality
we've been willing to make concessions
our negotiators time you just said you
want 14 for two percent yes yes for
everybody that's what we think people
deserve for everyone however it's
completely Insanity that's what we think
people do this is where you lose people
like me who believe actually the workers
should be properly renumerated I believe
they've had a tough time I'm glad you do
particularly in relation to the NHS went
out and clapped every Thursday I think
ambulance workers are fantastic friends
right claps don't pay the rent no
appears but if it doesn't pay the rent
demanding pay Rises which bankrupt the
country doesn't pay the rent it's not
going that actually has the opposite
effect that that sends inflation
means that the country basically goes
back no idea with that specific point
yes our position
is that workers deserve an RPI pay
increases however we've been involved in
negotiations and yes we have settled in
a number of cases
yes
I want 14.2 but but we've been willing
to negotiate here's the problem
I think what's happening is I think you
and your fellow union leaders all of
whom are labor people I think you sense
blood with the conservative government
understandably they're on their knees
they've been frankly catastrophic in the
last year in particular we've had one
prime minister couldn't last longer than
the lettuce right it's embarrassing for
the country but I think you're all
getting together and I think you've all
decided you're going to try and bring
this government down to get a labor
government in power and I think you
don't really care how much damage you
cause to Ordinary People to get there
and at that point I think you are doing
your own members a disservice because
they will also suffer from this process
if if that was a situation yes but we do
not care what the political colors of
the government are our laser focus is on
the workplace that's what we've been
doing we've been involved in over 450
disputes over the last year winning the
majority of those and winning 200
million pounds in extra earnings into
the pockets of our members we do not
care whether we deal with labor or
Tories we've had disputes against labor
care here's the problem you have in
particular you represent ambulance
workers right you
and if it was teachers or people in
those kind of professions if they have a
day off work it's not going to kill
people right it might put back their
education by a day and that's
unfortunate if it's not going to kill
people if your people go out on strike
there is a likelihood I would say that
some people are going to die because
they couldn't get an ambulance to them
in time and again I started with this
I'm going to finish with it how do you
live with that morally because you you
and your members are in a particular
position of service to the public which
actually means life or death
we could stop the strike if the
government is willing to negotiate what
did they do it doesn't have to happen
well then the responsibilities with the
government isn't it the government is
yes well not really you know you're the
ones going on speakers this happens one
day of strike action and yet the rest of
the Year this happens anyway the police
can't strike can they people are dying
in police cars right well they're a rule
stopping what's the difference what's
the difference between them and
ambulance workers I'll tell you what the
number of times the number of times I've
spoken to police officers or
demonstrations who say they wish they
could strike but they don't they're not
allowed to I don't think ambulance
workers should be allowed to strike
ambulance workers on average pay
starting salaries we are talking about
27 000. you said a number of ambulance
workers let me ask you another question
you said a number of ambulance workers
are now going to food banks yes how many
I'll give you the number well how do you
know because we speak to people what's
happening we because I spoke well 10 20
30 ambulance workers well how many is it
but we I I'm not going to be able to
tell you well you say these things how
many I find it unbelievable I frankly
found it I frankly find it pretty
unbelievable that an ambulance worker is
going to a food bank unless you can tell
me specifically who they are and how
many there are going to give you names
do they exist have you made that up no
that's insulting what's insulting
what's insulting is saying if you can't
back it up yes we can back it up because
this is where the major city you have no
idea how many this is what our members
are saying I cannot tell you across the
country how many paramedics and
ambulance workers have been to a food
bank I don't think anybody you believe
that you believe what it can give you
you believe it could be 10 20 30 more
I've the people that I've spoken to
I've spoken to 10 20 possibly more well
you can't remember what I'm saying
because I don't sit down and keep a tab
the reality is it's insulting
to believe that that doesn't happen no
what's insulting is you are saying
what's insulting is you saying something
that dramatic without supporting it with
any evidence I can't even remember you
can't even remember if you were told by
10 or 20 or first does it make it makes
a lot of difference what difference does
it make it's a lot of difference if
you're going to use if you're going to
use it's not a memory if you're going to
use as a propaganda stick it's not a
propaganda if you're good it's reality
well if it's reality reality show us
show people in the world show people we
have paramedics fine going to food bank
so you say nurses so you say and Pierce
they are why don't you go away and do
your research and find out how many
hospitals have actually set up their own
food banks for their own staff how much
do you earn that's the reality how much
do you earn that's irrelevant how much
you own because that's irrelevant you're
not going to tell me that's not as much
as you earn no but how much you earn it
makes no difference
how much do you earn it makes no
difference
it's irrelevant to the debate we're
having my earnings have no impact on you
know what you are as a union leader
right at the moment yeah absolutely
right absolutely because that's not the
debate and I know where you're trying to
take this where am I trying to say the
issue the issue is what am I trying to
think we have workers in the sixth
richest country in the world relying on
food banks that's a fact so you can't
tell me you can't tell me whether you
have any moral problem if people die
when they're of course I have a more I
get done with people all right so you've
now answered that question or anybody
now you finally have admitted you would
have a moral problem with it secondly
you won't tell me what you earn thirdly
you say a lot of paramedics nurses are
going to food banks for you and this is
people you've spoken to absolutely
you're not prepared to tell me who they
are how many there are
do you really think that everybody who
goes to a food bank wants Piers Morgan
to know wants your viewers tonight I
don't think they're going back I find it
very implausible when you say things
like it's 10 20 30. I'm not sure what
I'm getting at I probably remember every
one of my members who told me they were
going to be over a million and I might
better help with myself if I was only
the kind of money you were only you
won't tell us how much you were but you
don't know how much money what are you
saying here's because it's irrelevant to
the debate it's a public it's a matter
of public records right the reality fair
to tell me a public record salary is
irrelevant okay what is relevant is that
we perform for our members yeah as
opposed to the government as opposed to
anybody else we have okay over 200
million rounds by taking strike action
because strike action works okay that's
why our ambulance workers are taking
action well Merry Christmas good to see
you uh coming up Prince Harry says his
wife inspires him every day and they
want to be Advocates of healing yes
you've heard that right will the
Shameless substances ever stop I doubt
it that's where the money is right that
debate next
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
tonight we're on here in five minutes
yeah I'm just getting rid of some stress
fine same amount you've got someone at
guitar for me okay you're definitely out
there right yeah yeah I'm out here I
need some a-listers on the show yeah
we're just getting 5000 quick
Stadium
go back into football but I can't speak
Portuguese I probably have to get a beer
out here I can
out there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
shouldn't he put us all out of our
misery and stand down right now we'll
debate Matt Hancock in the program later
but first that you can Duchess of
Netflix were awarded for their heroism
in fighting Royal racism last night the
climate campaigners flew into New York
by private jet for the Robert F Kennedy
association's Ripple of Hope Awards
which were presented to them in their
case by Alec Baldwin who is possibly
about to face criminal charges for
accidentally shooting a woman dead on
the set of his movie so it was a really
Charming evening for everyone concerned
the suspices were on stage gushing about
healing because that's really what
they're all about isn't it healing so
one word you would really associate with
Megan and Harry as they trash their
family on an almost weekly basis their
dreaded Netflix series comes out
tomorrow and speaking for many of us the
sky reporter asked this
Harry are you putting money before
family are you putting money before
family how many questions Harry are you
putting money before family are you
putting money before family how many
questions literally the first time that
either of them have been challenged on
any of their allegations
Oprah never challenged them they won't
be challenged in this Netflix series
none of their cozy chats or podcasters
anyone ever ask some questions like that
and you know that is the burning
question are they now putting money
before their family are they trashing
the institution which gave them the
titles which they now ruthlessly exploit
for gazillions of dollars well joining
me now to discuss this author and
playwright Bonnie Greer Associates of
Daily Mirror Kevin McGuire and talk to
the contributor Esther cracker welcome
to all of you Bonnie welcome back thank
you
okay look this series is coming out uh
tomorrow we get the first three episodes
tomorrow morning in This Global event as
they call it they've just been given an
award for their heroism in standing up
to Royal racism without ever producing
to my knowledge any facts to support
these allegations where are we with
these two where does it end when does it
stop these are the same things they said
to Oprah Winfrey last year they're
continuing to attack the monarchy the
royal family of a new king not even
coronated yet the queen only died three
months ago of a new Prince of Wales all
of them waiting to see what the latest
Onslaught is who wins here apart from
their bank balance Excuse me yes
well you know and you know probably
better than a lot of people about the
celebrity space in the United States
that's where they are Megan Harry are
big celebrities in the United States you
also know as someone who's lived in the
United States who lives in the United
States that the Americans know nothing
about the royal family they know
absolutely nothing so what Megan and
Harry are doing is giving them their
definition of what the royal family is I
think we should just walk away from
Megan and Harry well we can
deliberately one way that we can and I'm
not putting them down is that we need to
have use this as an occasion for
ourselves in this country to have a
conversation about this I think it's
important
women not about them
but about what they're talking about I
think that's important the reasons
they're talking about structural racism
that's what Kerry hang on that's what
Kerry Kennedy
within the country
yes it's interesting because Gayle King
their friend open's best friend was
there last night and Jan Moore of the
daily mail after all the royal family
racist and Gayle King said no and they
don't think they are either talking
about the sussexes so I'm not quite sure
what you mean they're getting an award
for combating racism all right yeah
their best buddy says they don't think
the Royals are right so what is this all
about what is it this is about is the
standing of the United Kingdom in the
world
exactly exactly so we need to rescue it
and it's important to do that the Royals
aren't going to fight no no we're not
going to go on what we're doing right
now is we need to talk about there are
problems here like there are everywhere
and you know the the the the the
audacity of anybody in the United States
to talk about racism anywhere else is
actually hilarious right but we need to
take the occasion to talk about it we
can do it we can do it here because
there are issues what are we talking
about exactly not what we're talking
about the thing that happened to that in
gozi fulan yeah I was outrageous all
right we need to look and we need to do
it to talk about the funny in that case
an 83 year old woman made some
unfortunate remarks to a woman who was
at the palace she was named very quickly
she was held accountable and she was out
within 24 hours the difference with
Megan and Harry's they don't give any
names they give no facts they give no
evidence they simply say somebody yeah
the royal family you know said this
that's a reputation of this nation is
being held up exactly we need to take
charge of this conversation
I they actually won an award for
fighting structural racism they did
because that's that's how I like my
racism structured and uh constructed and
racist anyway but I think the the point
is that they they literally have done
nothing for people of of color for
instance so I don't understand this idea
that they're winning an awards on that
race what have they done
what you're saying is it's fake no no no
no what I'm saying it's not real no
listen the Persona that's being created
this country I'm not interested in
hearing again I'm talking about the
United Kingdom we're we don't look good
all right
because we need to confront I want to
hear you must have finished your thought
process of it I just think that they
they embody everything that's toxic
about this country and our conversation
around race I don't want to live in a
country where I can accuse someone of
being racist towards me and they can't
defend themselves which is exactly what
Megan and Harry are doing and they're
doing it knowing that the royal family
won't fight back so I think the best
thing to do would be to ignore them
because I don't feel comfortable
leveling aggregations that racism at
someone who can't defend I wouldn't
worry about it you can't ignore them
when they've got a Netflix series and
there's a book exactly exactly well what
has to happen what has to happen and
look there are no Rosa Parks Martin
Luther King talking but if she says she
suffered racism he says she suffered
racism there is racism in in Britain
there may be some in the royal family
they've got a name names put up and put
up or shut up and the royal family have
to come out and answer I'm sorry
[Applause]
William William came out after the Oprah
interview and said and very unusually
he's said to a reporter this is very
much not a racist family couldn't it be
more emphatic yeah no evidence has been
produced to say they are a racist family
you've got one lady in waiting to the
queen in her 80s saying unfortunate
things to a woman is about it I don't
think she should have said them the
moment that woman said she was born in
Britain and British end of conversation
she was she was held account within 24
hours she was gone the Duke of Edinburgh
used to make regular racist statements
he always passed them off as jokes now
My worry is this you're you are a
Republican you don't even believe in the
institution of monarchy I'm a monarchist
I love the monarchy and they bring us so
much to what our country stands for
around the world I'm really genuinely
worried now that these two are never
going to stop until they've caused
irreparable damage maybe not and with
the new king vulnerable obviously never
going to be as possible
as a monarchist you know this family's
gone through more than Megan and Harry
and and the royal family period they've
actually never they used to get there
they've never had a sustained attention
they've never had a sustained attack
they never have but this is the age that
we're in okay his great great uncle was
consorted with this is the King's son
this is the King's son standing on stage
receiving an award for standing up to
racism in his own family that's him I'm
talking about us right what we need what
can we do sit back what we can do is
have the conversations that we're having
within this country and be seen to have
those give me a favor tomorrow there's
this thing as tomorrow come back on
tomorrow once we've seen it but it is so
boring yes
you're right what is different here is
it's from inside it's sustained inside
Edward VII the Duke of Windsor was a
fascist sympathizer and admirer Hitler
but he shut up yeah after he died
wait a minute I'm doing is not look like
Andrew is the real scam wait a minute
from the inside
no I'm not I'm gonna leave it on that
Cliffhanger because we're gonna have a
lot more of this tomorrow night uh that
you're leaving us Bonnie thank you very
much you're new to sustain to talk about
other stuff
um tomorrow night we're gonna devote the
whole program to intersection of this
Netflix series three episodes and come
out we're gonna have a virtual audience
if you want to join in please email the
show at dmpmtv
um and we're going to debate this if
you've got a view either way I want to
hear from you it's not gonna be a
one-way traffic everyone knows my
opinion if you've got a different one
explain to me why I'm wrong but after
the break uh guilty of tax fraud Donald
Trump's company's been convicted by New
York jury and at the same time in one of
his big Senate hopes has also crashed to
birth Herschel Walker giving the
Democrats a big win and of course now an
increased majority in the Senate so is
he all over
become an election loser well it's
former top eight of the White House
kellyanne Conway will join me live I
suspect she will say it's not all over
but that face is giving nothing away
look
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
this is talk TV
well coming up on uncensored Legends
tonight is out of I'm a celebrity you
won't run standing for Parliament as a
conservative at the next election
yeah scenery goes the better if I was
looking so we'll debate that in a moment
but first it's been another disastrous
24 hours with Donald Trump suffering
several major blows in a single day
first the Trump organization was
convicted for a 15-year tax fraud scheme
and the committee investigated in the
January 6th Capital rights announced his
planning criminal referrals and his
hand-paked Republican candidate for the
Senate Herschel Walker crashed out in
Georgia handing Democrats an outright
majority now and that's been reported
that more classified documents will be
found in the Florida storage in uh
United
something unit rented by the former
president okay that didn't read right
but it was a unit um so is it all over
for Donald Trump or foolish to write him
off again well joining me now is Trump
former Aid at the White House kellyanne
call my kellyanne so it's all great to
talk to you again I've talked to you in
years uh obviously followed you a great
interest as you uh ran around the White
House
um often in my opinion defending the
indefensible uh are you now on my show
tonight to do the same
I don't even know what that means I was
there to communicate information to the
public that they otherwise wouldn't have
since uh Donald Trump cut out the
middleman and the middleman didn't like
it but I was happy to be part of the
policy team at the White House I said no
depressed secretary 45 minutes after he
was elected and many many times after
that but uh I think it was important to
have a number of Messengers to push back
against a lot of disinformation and hate
and also just to make sure that people
who otherwise don't have access to
presidential Communications coming out
of the White House have that you know
peers I think many Americans Miss many
people around the world probably miss
getting instant free of charge access to
a presidential communication whether
it's one of those tweets or the
president underwing Air Force One or
taking media into the Oval Office or
going to the Press briefing room I
didn't like every tweet I told president
Trump that he needs to tweet like we
need to eat it's just about better
choices sometimes you have a salad
sometimes you have a dessert it balances
out but um I don't know about counting
Trump out I think the Arc of his is of
his life of his career has been defying
the odds and pushing back against the
critics and the naysayers I mean I would
say here's the difference I would say to
Discount anybody right here's the
difference to me between previous times
when I might have agreed with you he is
a warrior and he will fight to the end
I'm sure and he obviously pulled off one
of the greatest you know shocks in
political history anywhere in the world
in 2016. but then you know he was a
massive vote winner out of nowhere and
it seems to me he's become increasingly
a big problem for the Republicans
because a lot of his picks are simply
not winning and Herschel Walker last
night lost in Georgia which means the
Senate majority increases for the
Democrats gives them more power they
very nearly held the house which would
have been unbelievable given the
position that most people thought were
Democrats were in and a lot of
Republicans are now blaming Trump and
there's all the baggage around him with
all these things going on in the
background from tax to this to that to
documents that miralaga and so on and
there's a belief as you know from a
number of Republicans or why are we
bothering to go through all this well
we've got this other guy DeSantis down
in Florida who had a stunning win in the
midterm elections he's about half
Trump's age he's Dynamic he's smart he's
got an amazing track record Yale Harvard
legal counsel to sealed team uh leaders
in in Fallujah and so on why persist in
what is looking like now somebody who's
a vote loser
you've asked a lot of that a lot there
that I'm not sure I can answer in the
limited time your producers have
provided me but let me try first pierce
you're right about 2016 but it didn't
come out of nowhere respectfully I was
the campaign manager in 2016. it is the
last time I've been on the president's
political team and I'm very critical of
this 2020 campaign his son-in-law Brad
paraskell the whole group within 1.4
billion dollars and you're running
against Joe Biden and you can't get the
job done we would have no January 6. we
would have no election fraud claims none
of it if they had just run outright and
overwhelmingly and they should have that
year so that aside remember I'm the one
Trump official with no subpoenas
scandals indictments and investigations
and I plan to keep it that way I
voluntarily testified to the January 6
committee last week and I did not take
the fifth for that testimony or any
question within the testimony so that's
over there on the question of Herschel
Walker it is true that President Trump
endorsed him and wanted him to run but
Herschel Walker's pushed back that it
was President Trump's idea he said I
wanted to run Mitch McConnell endorsed
herself Walker 13 months ago the whole
Republican party was behind this guy
Governor Brian Kemp turned over all of
his micro targeting data mining stuff
what he did do Herschel Walker bought
into this big lie that Trump had the
2020 election stolen when I sat down
with Trump in Mar-A-Lago in April I said
to him leave all that behind you it's
just going to become this massive stick
to vote against you that's exactly
what's happened he just won't let it go
nobody cares about 2020. nobody believes
he had it stolen from anyway and nobody
cares
I write about this in my Memoir here's
the deal peers it came out six seven
months ago and I very methodically lay
out the fact that it broke my heart
Donald Trump didn't get reelected I
wanted him to win I don't want Joe Biden
and Kamala Harris running this country
good God however
elections are about the future not the
past and I told him in 2020 you're
running out of time to show this
evidence I had long left the White House
but we were in touch and I said if you
have this evidence if your lawyers have
it you have to produce it you're running
out of time but you're right in terms of
people want a presidential candidate to
reflect their grievances not his or her
own and they want to hear about the
future and the vision I think Donald
Trump's best bet in running for the
presidency is very straightforward if
you strip away everything else and
that's a big if peers and you just say
this was your life under Joe Biden's
America this is your life on the Donald
Trump's America the gas prices the
supply chain Putin in Ukraine
um a nuclear capable Iran salivating in
Israel border security physical security
Financial Security all the rest that's
his best bet but when other things get
layered and stacked on top of that it
becomes a distraction now I just want to
say one thing about Herschel Walker I
think this is a bigger issue in the
Republican party we need to start going
after ballots and not just votes and
voters we have to bank these ballots
early peers I don't like the new way
that we vote in this country
look we're running out of time what I
would say about that is you're being
outflanked and outmaneuvered by the
Democrats and I find that's staggering
the Republicans so electorally
incompetent but that's another issue um
it's great to have you on the program
that's the biggest issue though
I'm sure it is there's a lot of fishing
going on in American police there's a
lot of fish you go on here it's great to
have you on and I would love you to get
you back when I suspect Trump pulls out
and DeSantis becomes a nominee please
come back then thank you peers good to
talk to the voters thank you nice to
talk to you all the best carrier
um Donnie you're one of the scientists
to react to that I mean I've always
actually uh liked kellyanne and she's
right she has given evidence to Jennifer
she's got an interesting marriage too
she certainly has because her husband
which I I think that's fine
um just quick reaction to that well
there was an old Hollywood term called
box office poison and that's what Donald
Trump is the Republican Party Joe Biden
will win if Donald Trump runs
yesterday this is what their up against
right this is the president United
States
it will construct a second fab here in
Phoenix to build chips three Nano chips
the three Nano chip chips that are three
Nano and you know what I'm saying
Nano no no I don't know the Republicans
are getting run around by that guy it's
unbelievable I love Joey's wheel what
one he's a real guy and listen hang on
he's real okay MP's not get there
cleaning himself up or anything else
he's messing up well you know what
whether he's real or not the truth about
Biden is that he is performing a hell of
a lot better than people thought thank
you and now the mid-tones were a
shatteringly bad midterm seats and this
is unprecedented because of trump yes
yeah I think I think Trump is hanging
around like a bad Smashbox
thank you for staying thank you we
managed to keep you for a little longer
than we thought before you jet off to
France when it comes to the other team
talking about Matt Hancock
um talking to people who really hanging
around like a bad smell yeah he's now
announced very pompously I'm not going
to stand at the next election why is he
standing for a minute longer as an MP
stand down man he is what I term as
unflushable he will not go away yeah he
and he needs to vanish because the thing
is I think Richardson needs to take a
leaf out of kirstberg he is making the
the conservative party look less
respectable than the labor party which
is a very bad look considering you want
to win re-election in 2024 but I think
the bigger issue here is the fact that
he was so arrogant to think that he
could have stood a chance again at the
next election I mean Rishi sunak has
been very clear that he was very
disappointed with him why hasn't he gone
now it's the 84 000 pounds a year
question yeah it keeps his salary at the
base you get the commons he's got
researchers he's got a certain
protection and a platforms he won't have
a violation no yeah exactly right
because right now they lose every
violation they ever have yeah that's
definitely the the case Rishi sunak will
not want him to to go he's been pretty
local but he but he's he's jumped before
he was pushed he was finished they've
turned against him in the in the
constituency I can't find a concept of
MP he was a good word to save for him
but we were down on that Pub but his
local yeah they were Furious yeah
um everything that he's been doing the
idea that he could be gallivanting
around munching kangaroo Destinies in
Australia going on with celebrity SAS
program writing a diary yeah which isn't
even really a diary by the look of it
it's just but you know we're revisiting
it he is a remnant of Boris Johnson's
donkey government but he's got a problem
though he's going to go before the
covert inquiry that diary all right uses
evidence and he will be questioned I
think he's going to be a very unpleasant
things happen to him in that inquiry I
think he's trying to sanitize his
involvement particularly around Care
thank you both very much indeed really
appreciate it Bonnie thank you for
coming in my pleasure we appreciate it
we're coming out tonight 50 years ago
today since man last took off for the
moon in a rocket why is it taking so
long to go back are we ever gonna go
back space Superstar astrophysicist
nearly grass Tyson
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
as I step up at the surface that Taurus
literal
we'd like to dedicate the first step of
Apollo 17 through all those you made it
possible well 50 years ago today
astronauts were launched to the moon for
the last time in NASA's Apollo 17
Mission but why haven't we gone back but
joining me is the man who knows
everything about the university
astrophysicist also the new book Starry
Messenger Cosmic perspectives on
civilization the great Neil deGrasse
Tyson rejoins me Neil and what a
wonderful waistco if I may start with
that
oh thank you thank you thank you I don't
want to show off for anything but now
look why have we not gone across the
pond we call it a vest that was another
part we call it a vest why have we not
gone back to the Moon in 50 years
I I have my own reasons for thinking so
I'm happy to share them with you
um when we first went to the moon we
have to remind ourselves why
all right we've there's been a lot of
cleansing of the memory of the
motivators of what motivated us to do it
in the first place it was in response it
was reactive
to the Soviet Union they beat us in
practically every space metric that
mattered over that time they had the
first satellite the first mammal which
was Leica the dog uh the first human
they had the first woman the first
dark-skinned person it was a a black
Cuban remember Cuba was of course part
of the Soviet Empire or uh
uh friends with them and so they they
had so many firsts
that we didn't that we said all right
how are we gonna what are we gonna do
let's go to the moon and so by the time
we got to the moon and realized Russia
actually isn't headed there it took some
of the steam out of sort of the
militaristic motivations that got us
there in the first place allow me to
remind you that this Apollo 17 was the
first mission to the Moon to have a
scientist on it and by the way it was
the last mission to the Moon right so we
tell ourselves where explorers
discoverers and it was really about
flexing muscle on a geopolitical well
now there's a kind of is it kind of
counter it's not a kind of counter
narrative to that exploring aspect
because I I remember when I was a kid
watching these Rockets go from Cape
Canaveral and feeling so enthralled and
the world used to watch these things and
now it seems like we've gone backwards a
bit like air travel air travel on
Concord used to be London and New York
in 2 hours 58 minutes now it takes twice
as long I don't understand how have we
gone back in these things Prince William
though Prince William criticized space
tourism and travel he said this
the idea this space races on at the
moment we've seen everyone trying to get
Space tourism going it's the idea that
we we need some of the world's greatest
brains and Minds fixed on trying to
repair this planet not trying to find
the next place to go and live
what do you make of that Neil you know
the argument that we've got climate
change we've got real pressing problems
here therefore we should suspend all
exploration off the planet until we save
this one
yeah I don't I don't like bad mouthing
Royals but if you allow me a moment to
do so let's go back 30 000 years let's
go back 30 000 years we're all living in
a cave and you have the cave Elders the
wise Elders in the back and then you
have some young whippersnapper youngins
who who they peer out the cave door this
cave door has hinges apparently in my
example but they move the Rock and they
look out and they see mountains and and
valleys and streams and and trees with
fruit on them and they go to the cave
elders and say we'd like to go explore
and the cave holders say no we have cave
problems that we have to solve first in
the cave before you exit the cave and
see what else is out there
that's what people sound like to me when
they say we have problems on Earth let's
solve them first before we go outside of
the earth without recognizing that by
the way uh your smartphone can find
Grandma's house in traffic because of a
system of satellites launched into space
you have full active video tracking of
hurricanes and storms and tsunamis okay
from images taken from space so to say
space is something other than what you
should care about just move back to the
cave because that's kind of where you
belong how important is somebody like
Elon Musk with SpaceX particularly with
the the satellites of course which you
know have been used for example in
Ukraine to help them in this war against
Russia what do you think of musk and
what he's doing in this area
yeah so musk um I think it one of the
biggest contributions he's making is
he's trying to drive down the cost of
access to space that's sort of a a a a a
a slightly buried objective here buried
not that anyone's purposefully burying
it they're just not noticing that this
is an important driver because if you
can draw if you can take down the cost
then other kinds of activities can then
unfold in space such as space tourism by
the way we let's think about it we I
don't know the future I don't have a
crystal ball but I can imagine a future
where space tourism is routine it
becomes commoditized and everybody you
save up a few vacation uh paychecks and
that'll get you into space you know
people will line up and want to do that
and there's nothing like seeing Earth
from space it is not the color-coded
countries that were drawn on your school
room Globe you see Earth as nature had
intended you to see with oceans and
lands and clouds that can change you
just by being a tourist in space so no I
don't I'm not with the people who are
saying don't do that let's stick to
Earth I can totally agree and if you use
that kind of logic you never do anything
because there's always something more
important that stops you doing something
fun
um you made some predictions on American
television very recently about what
would happen by 2050. two of them I
thought were quite likely self-driving
electric vehicles yep I think we're
gonna get that pretty well are a
visiting alien to Earth yeah I think
that's highly likely by 2050 but the
second one or third one on this list
humans will have the ability to
regenerate their limbs that was a real
little eye popper for me are we gonna
really better do that okay well
so I so let me let me put that in
context that appears in the books
chapter called exploration and Discovery
and I go through 150 years of the
exponential growth of Discovery and the
role that Science and Technology plays
in shaping civilizations and practically
everybody predicting at the beginning of
each 30-year period got it wrong yeah
that you can make linear predictions and
maybe some of that work but what
typically happens is a discovery comes
in from the side from above From Below
lived okay I'll tell you why so again
I'm not I'm not I so I gave my
predictions so that in 2050 people could
laugh at how wrong they were let's just
put that that's why I gave the
predictions so I said let me just try it
so why limbs because we you and I are
approximately the same age we learned
biology in an era where we said the Tree
of Life humans are at the top and we are
the most the Pinnacle of evolution I
remember hearing biologists say that and
teachers teach that excuse me it was
white men were at the top of the
evolution that depending on which
textbook you use but and I think to
myself suppose this is what a cosmic
perspective does to you suppose some
other animal made that same chart if
newts made that chart they would say
we're at the top because we can
regenerate Limbs and they would pity
humans on The evolutionary scale because
we can't all right
we're at the top I get it three
seconds I'm just saying because
regenerating limbs exists in the Genome
of other animals and we're all related
genetically okay all animals on earth
have common DNA so Grant take a snip of
that nip tuck it in US bada bing line up
the the veterans first I'm gonna get you
back on in 2015. maybe see if you feel
right about this but Neil move on out of
time I can talk to you all night thank
you you're always fantastic I appreciate
you coming on that's it for me keep it
unsensitive good night
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you